[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous propose de partir à
la découverte de voisin le Bretonneux la
ville qui compte près de 11000 habitants
est située à l'est du département
longtemps considéré comme un village
elle s'est métamorphosé pour devenir une
ville à la campagne nous partons à la
découverte de cette ville au passé
historique c'est en 768 dans un précepte
du roi Pépin qui apparaît pour la
première fois le nom de voisin sous la
forme latine visinho qui signifie
village les origines de la deuxième
partie du nom sont plus obscures si pour
certains Bretonneux signifierait
marécageux pour d'autres cela viendrait
de laavenue d'Anne de Bretagne sur le
[Musique]
territoire pour honorer cette histoire
nous partons à la découverte d'un lieu
emblématique de la commune le bassin de
la Sourderie situé à mi-chemin entre
Montini le Bretonneux et voisin il est
sorti de terre grâce à Ricardo beau fil
en
1984 l'architecte espagnol crée ce
bassin de 4 hectares quelques temps plus
tard c'est le quartier des templettes
juste derrière moi qui sort de terre de
style néoclassique ce quartier comprend
une centaine de logements sociaux et se
distingue par son architecture qui suit
le contour du bassin l'objectif de
l'architecte à l'époque réconcilier
l'architecture et l'habitat populaire
pour donner une autre image du logement
social
[Musique]
en contemplant l'architecture vous avez
peut-être remarqué un lieu verdoyant il
s'agit du verger de la Sourderie un
verger urbain et participatif où se
développe de nombreuses activités comme
l'écopaturage ou encore la protection de
la biodiversité nous partons à la
rencontre de Claudie soucher pour nous
faire découvrir ce poumon
vert alors bonjour Claudie soucher
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
petit peu ces vergers déjà le verger il
existe depuis début 2022 en fait on a
commencé les plantations on a à peu près
5 si espaces différents sur le verger et
justement l'idée de ce verger c'était de
créer un lieu où tout le monde peut
venir vraiment un lieu participatif où
chacun peut venir on le voir c'est ça
c'est complètement ouvert le but c'est
que euh ben euh les gens en fait ce soit
un lieu de rencontre et un lieu de de
collecte aussi enfin tout le monde peut
peut cueillir les fruits qui pousse ici
il y a aussi une volonté de de
sensibiliser à l'écologie hein vous vous
faites de l'écopaturage vous
sensibilisez à la biodiversité c'est des
enjeux qui sont importants aujourd'hui
le verger de la Sourderie donc il est
porté par par l'association Skay en
transition qui justement promut en fait
l'écologie une une économie de
ressources dans tous les sens du terme
en fait de vraiment faire attention à
son
environnement il est midi l'heure de se
restaurer nous sommes à la ferme de
voisin un restaurant emblématique de la
commune ici une cuisine authentique et
raffinée dans un cadre chaleureux mais
avant de manger petit détour par la
cuisine pour aller à la rencontre de son
chef romain
Giquel
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
petit peu votre établissement la ferme
de voisin c'est un corps de ferme un
véritable corps de ferme qui a été
transformé dans Ann 90 en restaurant fin
novembre 2006 j'ai repris l'affaire donc
ça fait presque 17 ans que je suis en
place ici ici le restaurant c'est un
lieu incontournable que tout le monde
connaît à voisin le bretonne qu'est-ce
qui fait que ça marche depuis toutes ces
années c'est que on connaît très bien la
clientèle locale comme le dirait très
bien un ami très proche notre spécialité
c'est l'accueil la convivialité et on
essaie vraiment que les gens passent un
bon moment quand ils viennent ici vous
présentez comme une cuisine raffiné et
authentique qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'est-ce qu'on trouve ici ça veut dire
qu'on trouve de la cuisine
traditionnelle française gastronomique
mais quelques petites pointes revisité
un petit peu de fusion des produits du
moment qu'on essaie simplement de
sublimer parce que la star c'est
toujours le produit à la base nous on
est juste là pour le mettre un petit peu
plus en valeur on va aller tester ça
j'ai donc fait confiance au chef en
optant pour les gambasses en sucette en
entrée le riz de veau et ses champignons
poilés et le baba au Rome en dessert
prix du repas 67 € après ce repas quoi
de mieux qu'une balade digestive à
quelques mètres du restaurant se trouve
l'église de la commune elle a été rénové
en
[Musique]
2018 constru est au 16e siècle au cœur
historique de la ville l'église
notreddame en sa nativité est un lieu
incontournable de la commune qui a
traversé les époques à quelques pas de
là une nouvelle église devrait bientôt
voir le jour avec plus de 800 places
l'église Saint-Joseph le bienveillant
sera érigé au cœur du quartier de la
remise l'objectif de ce projet
d'envergure permettre à la communauté
paroissiale de Montini et de voisins de
se rassembler pour pratiquer sa foi vous
l'avez compris voisin le Bretonneux est
une ville au assez historique mais elle
n'en reste pas moins moderne depuis
1998 l'association metasos fait battre
le cœur de la commune au rythme de la
musique son but promouvoir et développer
la musique amplifiée dans les communes
de Saint-Quentin en iveline je vous
propose qu'on parte à la rencontre de
[Musique]
l'association alors l'association
mthasos existe depuis
1998 ça commence à faire pas mal
d'années oui bon en effet ça commence à
faire plus de 20 ans l'assau est
construit comme ça sur vraiment des des
groupes qui avaient envie voilà de de se
retrouver de jouer et ensuite de se
produire en concert la force de
l'association on l'a dit he c'est que
c'est accessible à tout le monde c'est
également que vos studios ils sont
entièrement équipés on peut venir avec
presque rien finalement généralement il
y a pas besoin de venir avec tout tout
le matériel pour pouvoir jouer
finalement le strict minimum la tour en
l'air c'est l'ancêtre de la tour méwat
un de vos événements majeurs comment
c'est né la tour méwat a vu le jour en
2017 on a senti que c'était dans laad de
l'association de faire cet événement
fédérateur festif sur le territoire en
plus on a un site incroyable pour le
faire avec la cour et le jardin de
decoville en 2023 on a cartonné c'était
complet bon on est sûr qu'il y aura une
prochaine édition l'année prochaine vous
allez essayer de trouver quelque chose
de différent vous renouveler un petit
peu déjà on est on essaie de garder
quand même aussi cette esthétique donc
le vendredi on voulait vraiment mettre à
l'honneur plutôt les musiques
électroniques et ensuite le samedi on
est vraiment sur une esthétique un peu
plus grand public on va dire sur du rég
et du Deb même si on cherche toujours de
l'originalité quand même et c'est ici
que s'achève notre bienvenue à voisin le
bretonux moi ce que j'ai préféré ici
c'est l'héritage historique de la ville
que l'on retrouve dans tous les lieux
que nous avons visité à bientôt sur
tv78
[Musique]